Nossos cachorros nós vamos comprar pão é
5 minutos só você volta com a sacola de
pão você tá destrancando o portão
cachorro tá do lado de dentro pensando
assim ó se ele vacilar vou embora dessa
é
agora deixa ele abrir dois dedos a mais
para ele ver né você abre a porta o
cachorro começa a gritar em casa porque
a família fica que o cachorro foi
embora Maria o cachorro saiu lá
vem a Maria com as mão cheia de arroz eu
falei para cuidar do portão idiota ei
gleon cachorro saiu já falei para deixar
essa solta dentro de casa aí
começa a
gritaria a família faz um mutirão já viu
sai todo mundo detrás dos carros abaixo
dos
carros
bosta que é os nome que a gente bota em
cachorro né
bosta e
bosta